and the key is you don't have to be a
genius investor I mean our millionaire
study found that most of them were
mediocre investors that just invested
consistently over a long period of time
in a 401k and a Roth IRA in growth stock
mutual funds and they didn't even pick
the best ones
they just went all right this is not a
super volatile investment it's not a
single stock it's not crypto I'm just
going to invest in my retirement plan
and they became millionaires by doing
that and the average age was 49 so
you're right on track Ken look at that
they started at 49 no they became
millionaire average age for the
millionaires in our study of over ten
thousand I see so somewhere younger some
are older gotcha but it just goes to
show you if you just follow a proven
plan you don't have to make a bajillion
dollars or be a doctor or a lawyer you
can build wealth on your terms without
having to strike it rich or get an
inheritance or do all these crazy things